للمتابعه بالعوده الى احداث غزه الميدانيه
لا سيما الميدانيه من ها معنا من رفح
مراسل جزيره هشام زقوت هشام اذا كيف بدا
او بدات الساعات الاخيره في
القطاع استمرار للقصف الاسرائيلي قصف عنيف
تشهده المنطقه الوسطى في قطاع غزه لا سما
منطقه الزوايده ومخيم المغازي وربما هاتين
المنطقتين هما الاعنف حتى الان من في او
الاكثر حده في القصف الاسرائيلي قصف مدفعي
قصف من الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه ما
بين فينه واخرى ايضا قنابل دخانيه تطلقها
المدفعيه والاليات العسكريه الاسرائيليه
على منطقه وبلده الزوايده ومخيم الز مخيم
ايضا المغازي يتعرض الى قصف عنيف من
المدفعيه ومن الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه ولكن حتى الان لم يعرف بعد ما
الذي يتم استهدافه في هذا المخيم الصغير
والمقتضي يحتوي على مباني بدائيه كثير من
هذه المباني هي من الصفيح وبالتالي القصف
الاسرائيلي او اي قصف اسرائيلي يحدث دمار
هائل في المنازل المدنيه الفلسطينيه في
مخيم المغازي هناك ايضا اصوات اشتباكات
تسمع ما بين الفينه والاخرى على ما يبدو
انها ناجمه عن اشتباكات ما بين عناصر
المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
المتوقفين من شارع في اطراف مخيم المغازي
حتى الان لم تعرف بعد الاماكن التي توغلت
فيها قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي او
بالتحديد اي الشوارع التي ت تواجد فيها
قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي كانت تتواجد ما
بين مخيم المغازي ومخيم البريج في شارع
السكه وايضا كانت تتواجد على اطراف
الاطراف الشرقيه لمخيم المغازي كذلك على
اطراف على الاطراف الغربيه على شارع صلاح
الدين عند عند مدخل مخيم المغازي وهناك
يعتلون بعض القناصه
الاسرائيليين المباني المرتفعه في على
مدخل مخيم المغازي بالتحديد على شارع صلاح
الدين ويطلقون النار على كل من يحاول
الخروج من المخيم او حتى حتى الدخول الى
المخيم وبالتالي المعلومات الوارده من هذا
المخيم هي معلومات شحيحه هم حتى السكان
الذين يتواجدون في المخيم هم يرصدون اصوات
الانفجارات اصوات عنيفه على مدار الساعه
قصف من المدفعيه الاسرائيليه لكن لا
يعرفون ما الذي يجري خارجا لا سما وان
القصف متواصل وحتى الخروج ربما من المنزل
صعب للغايه في ظل ايضا تحليق طائرات مسيره
كواد كابتر تطلق النار على المواطنين
الفلسطينيين الذين يسعون حتى نزوح او
الخروج من هذا المخيم والانطلاق الى دير
البلح وربما دير البلح التي طلب الجيش
الاسرائيلي من السكان ان يتوجهوا اليها
قصفها الجيش الاسرائيلي هذه الليله بعنف
غارات اسرائيليه عنيفه على دير البلح
وكلها استهدفت منازل مدنيه فلسطينيه ثلاثه
منازل حتى الان تم استهدافها من قبل الجيش
الاسرائيلي والمقاتلات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه 18 شهيدا في هذه المنازل
استشهدوا وتم انتشال جثامين هؤلاء هؤلا
الشهداء الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى في دير
البلح وهناك ايضا عشرات من المصابين على
الاقل هناك 100 اصابه وصلت منذ 24 ساعه
الى مستشفى شهداء الاقصى واكثر من 73
شهيدا هي حصيله كل هذه الليله منذ منتصف
الليل او منذ 24 ساعه في وسط قطاع غزه
وبالتالي اعداد الشهداء ترتفع شيئا فشيئا
من جراء حده هذه الغارات في وسط القطاع
ايضا مخيم النصيرات يتعرض الى قصف عنيف من
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه وكذلك من
المدفعيه المناطق الشرقيه والشماليه تتعرض
الى قصف ما بين فينه واخرى من قبل
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه منطقه شارع العشرين
وما بين المنطقه الواقعه ما بين شارع
العشرين في مخيم النصيرات وشارع صلاح
الدين وهي المنطقه الشرقيه للمخيم تتعرض
الى قصف عنيف تحوم فيها طائرات كوات كابتر
اسرائيليه و تطلق النار على المواطنين في
تلك المنطقه ايضا المناطق الشماليه ارض
المفتي ومنطقه المغرا ومنطقه مدينه
الزهراء تتعرض هي الاخرى الى قصف عنيف من
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه كذلك ايضا المدفعيه
تكثف من قصفها لمناطق شرق مدينه خانيونس
وهي المناطق الواقعه الى الشرق من شارع
صلاح الدين كذلك الواقعه الى الغرب ومنطقه
وسط البلد باتت تتعرض الى قصف عنيف من
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه وهناك غارات ما بين
الفينه والاخرى تنفذها الطائرات الحربيه
الاسرائيليه في تلك المنطقه بالاضافه الى
المحور الجديد الذي باتت تستهدفه الطائرات
والمدفعيه وهي المنط المنطقه الشرقيه
الجنوبيه لخان يونس منطقه قيزان النجار
وايضا جورت اللوت وهي مناطق حديثه العهد
في القصف الاسرائيلي او في تكثيف عمليات
القصف الاسرائيلي على هذه المناطق حيث بات
القصف عنيفا على تلك المناطق والجيش
الاسرائيلي يكثف ايضا القصف المدفعي
بالاضافه الى عمليات اطلاق النار
والاشتباكات الحاصله والتي تسمع ما بين
الفينه والاخرى في تلك المناطق هشام ايضا
نتحول الوضع الانساني في رفح حيث انت
وايضا في بقيه المناطق في قطاع
[موسيقى]
غزه الاوضاع المعيشيه صعبه للغايه هي
طوابير طوابير على المياه حتى ان وجدوا
مياها في رفح او حتى في كل المناطق
الفلسطينيه في مناطق المخيمات في الوسط
وفي الجنوب وحتى في الشمال الاوضاع صعبه
للغايه في شمال القطاع ومدينه غزه الاوضاع
ربما هي الاكثر خطوره لا سما وان
المساعدات لا تستطيع الوصول الى تلك
المناطق الناس بالك تستطيع الحياه في ظل
نقص حاد في المستلزمات الاساسيه وكل
مقومات الحياه في مدينه غزه وشمال القطاع
لا يوجد حبه قمح واحده المياه بالكاد
يستطيعون الحصول عليها من جراء استمرار
القصف الاسرائيلي وايضا حمله وتدمير
الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه والدبابات
الاسرائيليه التي ربما انسحبت في من كثير
من المناطق وباتت على اطراف مدينه غزه
وكذلك على اطراف شمال القطاع لكن الواقع
في داخل ه هذه المناطق صعب للغايه هناك
اكتظاظ سكاني في هذه المناطق في جباليا في
مدينه غزه ولا يجدون لا غذاء ولا ماء
صالحا للشرب والمساعدات التي تصل عبر معبر
رفح هي شحيحه وبلكات يعني تصل الى حتى رفح
لان كل المناطق ما بعد رفح هي تتعرض الى
قصف اسرائيلي وبالتالي ايضا المساعدات
لاتصل الى شمال القطاع والى مدينه غزه
وبالتالي الناس تعاني بشكل كبير هناك في
تلك المناطق الاوضاع ليست افضل حالا في
مناق وسط القطا مخيم النصيرات مخيم البريج
مخيم المغازي وبلده الزوايده وهذه المناطق
هي ربما الاكثر حده في هذه الغارات لا سما
وان ال العمليه البريه التي بدات من مخيم
البريج بدات فقط قبل عده ايام وبالتالي
باتت هذه المخيمات محاصره الناس تتواجد في
داخلها في مراكز الاواء تتعرض الى القصف
لا تستطيع لا سياره اسعاف ولا سيارات دفاع
مدني الدخول الى هذه المخيمات وبالتالي
كيف ستدخل المساعدات كيف سيدخل الغذاء كيف
سيدخل الدواء والان التهديد الاكبر هو
لمستشفى شهداء الاقصى وهو المستشفى الوحيد
الذي يعمل في وسط قطاع غزه بالاضافه الى
بعض ال الى مستشفى واحد ايضا هو مستشفى
العوده في مخيم النصيرات ولكن حتى مخيم
النصيرات يتعرض الى قصف عنيف ما بين
الفينه والاخرى ومستشفى شهداء الاقصى بات
التهديد عليه كبيرا في ظل تحليق طائرات
مسيره وتطلق النار على ساحه هذا المستشفى
على غرفه العنايه الم مكثفه في هذا
المستشفى تعرضت ايضا للاستهداف وبالتالي
خروج هذا المستشفى بحسب وزاره الصحه عن
العمل ما يعني ان هناك كارثه كبيره ستحدث
في وسط القطاع لا سما وانه المستشفى
الاساسي المستشفى الرئيسي ولا يوجد اي
مستشفيات وهو بالكاد اصلا مجازا نطلق عليه
مستشفى هو مستوصف كبير ويقدم كان
الاسعافات الاوليه في ظل في ظل النقص
الحاد في المستلزمات والادويه والاسره
وبالتالي الاوضاع المعيشيه للسكان من كل
الجوانب من ناحيه من الناحيه الصحيه من
الناحيه المعيشيه الانسانيه هم بالكاد
يستطيعون توفير ادنى مقومات الحياه وفي ظل
استمرار الحصار بكل تاكيد ستكون الاوضاع
والايام القادمه صعبه للغايه في ظل هذه
الاوضاع الصعبه واستمرار القصف رفح مراسل
الجزيره هشام زقو شكرا جزيلا لك